prince william has been fairly withering
in his criticism of space tourism in an
interview saying the world's greatest
mind should be focused on fixing this
planet rather than further exploring
space
has he got a point julia
i'm absolutely with prince william on
this one i think he's absolutely right
um the enormous amount of energy as we
heard earlier in the program and the
enormous amount of of carbon emissions
associated with that it takes to get
somebody into space just for a quick
look at the earth from space and to feel
weightlessness i mean i think that's
that's really shocking and also the
amount of money that's being spent that
could be spent on helping us with the
transition to net zero or indeed helping
us with the the crucial restoration of
nature that we need to be doing here on
our planet stop looking at our planet
from apart far and start making our
planet better um as prince william has
been encouraging them to but kel do we
learn a lot about our own planet from
looking at it from afar i mean look at
what tim peake our very own astronaut
said more than 50 percent of climate
data comes from space assets so can't we
learn about the the progress that we're
making as far as tackling climate change
goes from space
yeah i mean there is there is a slight
argument for that i would agree i think
you know space exploration and space
tourism are two very different things if
you're going just from the tourist side
of things uh julia's so right it makes
absolutely no sense and it's quite
insulting to be honest with you the
space exploration has definitely
afforded us um you know the chance to
look at research like this and it's
definitely probably provided some form
of technology but i think given now
where we're at we're at a very critical
point when it comes to trying to reverse
the effects of climate change and i
don't think the solutions are going to
be found out in space in fact the
solutions are right here on earth and i
think we should be putting time and
energy into these now while we are at
this crucial point and maybe further
down the line it can be something that
can be revisited but but for now it just
doesn't seem to make much sense and that
feels like more of a distraction to be
honest with you we're looking beyond the
planet rather than looking in as as judy
also said that
so how do you re-direct those funds
towards um more earthbound
priorities at julia what's your your tip
well well i would say there are some
crucial things as
cal mentioned um to do with space i mean
the satellite monitoring is going to be
absolutely critical for us
to know whether we're losing more
rainforest whether the commitments
countries are making to to planting new
forest and woodland whether those
forests and woodlands are being
maintained in healthy condition all of
those things are going to be helped by
satellite technology and satellite
monitoring so there's plenty that space
can do as tim peake has said to help us
so if you want to invest in space
invest in some of these things that are
going to help us with the transition
with monitoring the transition with
helping to determine whether carbon
offsets are actually real and are
actually removing co2 from the
environment
okay well it's a fascinating um
discussion kel i'm afraid we're out of
time so we can't come back at you i know
you were worried about space junk as
well but we'll revisit that another time
kel spellman thanks very much indeed and
thanks to to julia king good to get your
thoughts tonight
you